de la peinture du champ du violon mais
surtout du piano pour rendre hommage aux
victimes de la guerre en ukraine
daria et anastasia est organisée en
quelques mois un concert caritatif pour
venir en aide à leur pays ses deux amis
se connaissent depuis longtemps car
elles ont fait leurs études ensemble au
conservatoire national de kiev dès que
la guerre a commencé le 24 février daria
tout de suite accepté d'accueillir
anastasia et sa famille chez elle à
voisins le bretonneux organisé ce
concert était donc une évidence pour
elle c'est très très important parce que
déjà le l'argent récolté aujourd'hui il
sera envoyé en ukraine à à la ville de
czerny riffs qui était détruite à 70% et
cinq hôpitaux sur cet été bombardé et
donc cet argent ils voient à partir à
l'aide des l'ukraine porté par la ville
de voisins-le-bretonneux et en
partenariat avec l'association du lion's
club daria a réussi à connecter 2000
euros et dans la salle l'émotion était
très présente le fait d'associer
finalement la beauté de la musique et
pète la dureté des images t20 contrat ce
qui se crée qui bon qu'ils pouvaient
toucher quoi elle concerne une très
grande qualité avec des artistes du
talent ça se voit ça s'entend et du coup
c'est extrêmement émouvant parce que l
ont accompagné sa d'image et
oui je crois qu'on avait tous les larmes
aux yeux parce que on se rend compte de
l'atrocité de cette guerre de la
stupidité surtout l'inutilité totale de
ce que de ce combat qui privent les gens
de leur vie de leur famille de leur
maison et à la fin du concert les élus
de voisins-le-bretonneux ont tenu à leur
faire une surprise
[Musique]
cet événement caritatif et est double
puisque les peintures de marina diplômé
de l'académie nationale ukrainienne des
arts et olga élèves à l'école des
beaux-arts de versailles au sein de la
maison 2 coville ont également permis de
récolter des fonds pour les réfugiés
krainer
étrange
[Musique]